se faire entendre manifester sa colère
en musique
interpellé les passants et
automobilistes ces élèves déterminés ont
donc pris le relais des enseignants pour
rappeler le malaise existant dans leur
établissement
je vais faire passer comme message que
tout ça c'est pas valliot c'est pas bien
pour et les élèves et les profs
donc on peut pas travailler dans ces
conditions là qu'il faut que ça change
il faut que ça s'arrête depuis le 28
novembre la parole se libère face
distille aux graves dysfonctionnements
qui touche le management et la gestion
du proviseur des problèmes que ces
étudiants ont tenu à exprimer à la
direction de la dame et je suis là avait
déjà entendu et que nous on revient
encore une fois manifesté contre sa donc
là on a eu quand même bon retour on a
pris en compte le fait qu' aujourd'hui
on a une partie effectivement des
apprenants qui s'associe à une partie du
corps enseignant pour comme ils
l'expriment retrouver de la sérénité au
sein de l'établissement et pouvoir
suivre leur scolarité leur doléance vont
être relayée au niveau national en
attendant le lycée reste fermé le
proviseur que nous avons contactés ne
souhaite pas s'exprimer